quoi que ce soit tu penses m'avoir vu je l'ai
enterré avec ma famille comme si Neto
rejoignait l'apocalypse pour anéantir la race humaine
tu n'es plus des étudiants
tu es des x-men je vais leur apprendre
à se battre allons y  les tempêtes de guerre ont rendu cette
obscurité à son
apocalypse la rend plus forte et plus
puissante le
style est très mortel et elle n'a pas
peur de se salir les mains l'
ange est très en colère à Causton l'ombre de la
mort de l'autre côté de la ligne
certains croient que le premier mutant est
né des milliers d'années  il y a quelque temps, il était une
sorte de Dieu, je pense qu'il va renaître l'
apocalypse est le mutant original est
tout-puissant et il magnifie tous
leurs pouvoirs il a décidé de porter un
jugement sur le monde alors il a rassemblé une
équipe de mutants pour anéantir la race humaine
il  a toujours eu quatre adeptes comme les
quatre cavaliers de l'apocalypse
comme jamais il ne s'est senti père comme ça
avant de pouvoir nous contrôler tous l'apocalypse a
rassemblé ses cavaliers et son programme est
beaucoup plus catastrophique
apocalypse dans le cheval  vendeur très
puissant le monde entier est en jeu
les cendres du long
vous